la fronde vita à l'art des vendanges et
que ce soit dans le nord ou dans le sud
de la france c'est la pleine période de
la récolte avec toujours les mêmes
interrogations sur la qualité de ce
millésime 99 qui sera très recherchée
symboliquement nous en parlerons dans un
instant avec notre spécialiste jean yves
perrin mais nous commençons par les
constatations sur le terrain direction
tout d'abord le bordelais éric perrin
c'est un autre et philippe dumas il nous
emmène sur l'île margaux le nom est déjà
une invitation au voyage
c'est un bout de terre entre le ciel et
l'eau un vignoble qui flotte sur
l'estuaire de la jirs de ce soit pour
visiter ou pour venir faire les
vendanges le bateau reste le seul moyen
d'accès venir à l'île margaux c'est
toujours larguer les amarres avec la
terre ferme
pas vraiment le temps d'admirer le
paysage il est 8 heures la troupe des
vendangeurs qui campent sur l'île se
prépare quoi vous êtes venu faire je ne
gagne de l'argent quand même colonie de
vacances pourquoi pas la moyenne d'âge
est de 20 ans depuis plusieurs années le
domaine fait exclusivement appel à des
étudiants venus de toute la france
et oui les inondant c'est pas comme les
cures impossible de sécher ou de dormir
discrètement au fond du rang qui est le
porteur ici là en cherchant bien il ya
un point commun entre les vendanges et
les études on a le choix entre plusieurs
branches comprenait plusieurs options la
première toupet les grappes avantage en
marche - inconvénients on est toujours
blessé pasqua
la fin de la journée il ya des
courbatures partout une à genoux toute
la journée
deuxième option forte avantage on voit
du pays inconvénient c'est lourd 15 à 20
kg de raisin dans chaque bras plus de
kilos de boussou chaque bonne ont
préféré couper aux portes et coupé ouais
pourquoi j'ai passé moins fatiguant ya
pas de brouillard pas la moue sur les
votes
c'est là un peu fatigué ce matin voilà
ça tire et puis parce qu'en plus les
djeuns ça fait la fête
une ambiance qui n'est pas pour déplaire
aux îliens pur et dur ce sont des gens
qui sont formidables un capital et venir
ici
d'ici là une bo pareil c'est agréable
d'être avec les jeunes
c'est vrai que les adultes n'arrivent
pas toujours à les comprendre mais en
fin de compte quand on nous on vit une
dizaine de jours avec eux ils sont super
forts
si le climat de l'île est bénéfique pour
les hommes il l'est aussi pour le raisin
le fait qu'ici on fasse le tour du
propriétaire en bateau n'est pas
seulement anecdotique l'estuaire de la
gironde et bonne mer
on bénéficie d'un petit micro climat et
au moment des jeux les printanières on
est moins atteint que d'autres côtés
quoi que sur le continent
la drôle de colonies de vacances n'est
pas terminé il reste encore une semaine
de vendanges le temps de prendre
quelques habitudes des îliens comme dire
au moment du départ
retour sur le continent